Gravity affects us in ways we didn’t expect.
We know this by observing frogs.
That’s right, frogs.
Hi all.
I’m Ian O’Neill, space producer for Discovery
News, and I wanted to chat a little about
a frog named Xenopus Laevis and a force called
gravity.
The Xenopus is also known at the African clawed
frog and biologists have been astonished by
how big its cells are.
On average, animal cells on Earth are around
10 microns wide, but the Xenopus cells are
much, much larger.
If a human cell was the size of a house, a
Xenopus cell would be the size of the Empire
State Building!
Why is there such a wild size difference?
In a new study published in Nature Cell Biology,
researchers studied the architecture of the
cells found inside Xenopus eggs.
These huge cells are markedly different from
human cells in that they contain many membrane-less
compartments inside the nucleus.
These compartments are liquid-like drops filled
with RNA and proteins known as “nuclear
bodies.”
In human cells, these nuclear bodies are supported
by membranes that provide structure, preventing
them from turning to mush.
But with few membranes to support the nuclear
bodies inside Xenopus cells, why doesn’t
gravity take over, causing all the stuff inside
the nucleus to sink to the bottom?
There must be something countering this gravitational
effect.
After injecting a magnetized microscopic bead
into one of the cells, the researchers were
able to exert a magnetic field on that bead
and observe how it moved.
They found that the bead (and nuclear bodies)
were being held in place by a web of proteins
known as an “actin mesh”.
When the magnetic field was switched off,
the bead returned to its original position
as if it were embedded inside a cube of Jello.
As a space scientist I’ve always been fascinated
by how the space environment can impact biology
-- simply removing the force of gravity in
experiments on the International Space
Station has led to breakthroughs in medicine,
cell growth and developments in new therapies
for disease.
But as demonstrated by this little frog, Nature
has a few tricks up its sleeve to mimic a
gravity-less environment inside the Xenopus
cells, thereby boosting its size, making it
more durable and more adept at supporting
life.
Wouldn’t it be cool if we could develop
this microscopic mesh for industrial purposes,
maybe it would make a good shock absorber?
Who knows!
What do you think we could learn from this
fascinating research?
Let me know in the comments below and please
subscribe for more DNews every day of the
week.